this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday September 7th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
earlier this year China's cyberspace
regulator set out rules compelling
companies to share information about
their algorithms the systems that power
all the big online platforms
the goal of gathering this information
is to stop the negative effects of
algorithms from spreading misinformation
and infringing on privacy to online
harassment but experts warn that trying
to directly regulate algorithms could be
tricky since many of them adapt in
unpredictable ways based on user
Behavior
joining us to discuss how China is
taking on this Challenge and what other
countries might take away from their
efforts is our China Tech reporter Karen
Howe hi Karen thanks for being here hi
Zoe thanks so much for having me so with
Chinese regulation went into effect in
March in an effort to tighten controls
of algorithms underpinning the internet
then what happened the latest move is
they announced that they successfully
got submissions detailed documentation
from some of the most influential
internet companies in the country so
that's companies like Baidu Alibaba
tencent which makes the sort of
all-encompassing WeChat app and there
are about 30 algorithms from two dozen
companies that are supposed to be sort
of the core of the recommendation
systems of these platforms that have now
been filed to the top internet regulator
to describe exactly what they're doing
so what exactly has been made public and
what are Regulators getting from this
yeah so this is sort of like the first
step to this broader regulatory campaign
that China's trying to pursue where they
sort of almost very logically like if
they want to gain control over
algorithms they first want to gain
visibility so they're trying to get as
much information from companies to just
wrap their heads around what exactly
these systems even do but thus far
companies haven't actually submitted
code they haven't actually submitted
like highly technical information it's
actually more of a lay person's summary
of the operations of these algorithms so
what are the inputs what is the type of
user data that these companies are
collecting ultimately what is it trying
to do is it meant to personalize like a
social media app or is it meant to rank
search information in a search engine so
it's actually relatively high level
information but there's sort of a lot of
vagueness and uncertainty right now
around how much much more information
the government is going to start asking
these companies eventually
what do we know about beijing's kind of
thinking behind this and why it's
specifically gone after algorithms so
people familiar with the government's
thinking actually told us that Beijing
in general hadn't really been attuned to
this issue so in the US and EU there's
been like pretty long-standing debates
about the idea of how are we supposed to
regulate Tech platforms how are we
supposed to keep the internet safe and
algorithms have been a really big part
of this debate and this discussion but
for Beijing apparently the focus on
algorithms didn't really kick off until
Tick Tock was almost sold to an American
buyer so Tick Tock is obviously the
wildly popular social media app but it's
owned by a Chinese company called bite
dance and when it was going up for sale
it was right around the time when
Chinese Regulators also passed an export
control ban on information
recommendation technology and so it
suddenly became unclear whether Tick
Tock would be sold
with its algorithm and that suddenly
made bitters not as interested in buying
Tick Tock and this basically tipped off
Beijing to thinking oh wow algorithms
seem to be really important we should be
looking into this more and from there
they sort of realized how it could also
be extremely influential for public
opinion for social mobilization and that
was what kicked off these set of
regulatory actions to really get a
handle on these systems you mentioned
some other countries that have kind of
thought about this in the past have any
other nations taken these kinds of
regulatory steps to rein in algorithms
so in the U.S the short answer is no and
in the EU what's interesting is there's
been a pair of Acts that just recently
passed in July the Digital Services Act
and the digital markets act that try to
tackle the same question but actually go
about it in a more roundabout way so
with the digital Services act what the
EU tried to do was say okay we're not
not going to regulate algorithms
directly we're just going to tell Tech
platforms that they need to do
assessments of their entire products to
understand what the risks are and then
they have to decide how to mitigate
those risks and that could involve
tweaking the algorithm so it's a much
more indirect approach but the European
Union also thinks it's a more rights
preserving approach it's a more
democratic approach but critics also say
that it's sort of sidesteps some of the
issues and doesn't have as much teeth as
China's approach to actually trying to
literally get at the algorithms
themselves I mean is it even possible to
regulate these algorithms you know so
many of them are not concrete they
change they learn from users habits so
how do you actually rein them in as a
regulator
this is like the biggest question that I
think trying to sort of opened up no
one's really tried this before and so no
one really knows if it's going to work
but from like the basic principles of
this technology it would be incredibly
hard if not maybe impossible so internet
algorithms today are mostly based on
machine learning and machine learning is
when you have algorithms that aren't
actually written out explicitly as a set
of rules but they're actually just
learning from user data user Behavior to
figure out the rules themselves but most
machine learning systems are black boxes
like the people who coded them the
people who developed them can't actually
print out exactly what rules these
algorithms learned from the data so from
that perspective just like seeing the
code on these algorithms doesn't
actually get you very far in
understanding their logic and what
complicates it further is social media
platforms like Facebook or Tick Tock
they don't actually just use one
algorithm they use hundreds or thousands
of these interlocking algorithms and
they as you said are constantly being
updated based on a very complex stream
of user generated content user Behavior
so trying to fully understand every
dimension of what's going on is pretty
much impossible and therefore
controlling it is very very improbable
okay so what does this mean for Chinese
internet users you know post this
regulation coming into play
you know what's interesting is in the
Chinese context it might not actually
mean much different than what we've
already seen happening when cgp came
into Power there's been like a slow
tightening of a tightening and narrowing
of what discourse is actually allowed in
the public sphere and on these internet
platforms and from that perspective like
even if China ultimately can't figure
out exactly how to get these platforms
or this discourse to do exactly what it
wants to companies will ultimately still
take it as a signal that they need to
continue this trend of tightening down
narrowing down the discourse so in that
sense maybe it doesn't necessarily
matter in the Chinese context what I
think is particularly interesting about
this effort is more of what the rest of
the world might be able to learn learn
from its successes and failures because
it is the only attempt globally to
address this issue so directly through
the algorithmic level all right that's
our reporter Karen Howe Karen thanks so
much for joining us thank you so much
Zoe
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]